there we go mr. weh leg ah you see I was
right now I got it I gotta get ready
here I can't I can't fool around I've
been beaten many times my opponent has
also disallowed take-back so I better be
I better be very cautious and they're
also saying that the stream is muted is
it can I can I believe that one can I be
a believer in that one okay I might have
to throw out some duds he doesn't need
my advice let me get this in here
if c4 or I'll have to we have to be very
cautious about bringing that Bishop out
but now do I have any problems do i I
really just want to take this night I
think before he pivots on this square
I'm considering it should I do that ship
takes tonight this pond is gonna come
under some heavy fire yeah probably not
a good idea you know let's not do that
I'm gonna play here I'm looking at c5
and queen b8 maybe yeah I mean I can't
okay well forget about Bishop takes
Knight now it'll be this night that ends
up coming here let's go
c5 may be rook c8 first something we're
gonna have a lot of tension going on
with the scene d pawns I know it there
we go
I knew it I knew it
so what do you do here take or just
maintain this Center could end up with
the resulting hanging pawn structure if
I do this is everything gonna be okay so
far it's symmetrical kind of except for
the bishops
okay copycat game with the pawn
structure strip the Board of everything
but pawns and everything is the same and
I'll actually you know everything is the
same except for the bishops there okay
tension between these guys I got a take
and I throw another piece on here or I
just play my rook here I don't know what
I want to do
how about Castle Knight here is that
gonna be a problem
rook here eventually Queen here is that
gonna be annoying hmm it's castle I'm
not fearful of that Knight coming to c6
should I be
maybe rook c8 Queen c7 Queen here or
Queen to b7 i think i want to get queen
on b7 if pond takes pawn what do i do
recapture with the pond because i can't
deal with the knight coming to c4 k na
no way if take stakes then i could be
putting in a third attacker on the
knight on e5 that's one thing that could
maybe be benefiting me in some way but
maybe my most well maybe my biggest
concern is this knight move to c6 so i
want to take that out of the equation
first rook c8 watches over c6 but i am
fearful of queen coming out here I'm
gonna throw a third attacker on the
night something needs to be done now
palm push then I could look into here
okay hang on now hang on what about chop
chop Bishop here remove the knight get
to e4 you catch that one chop chop
Bishop here take a knight plan tonight
take a night looking for a good versus
bad Bishop situation I don't think it's
that clear it's not as squeaky clean as
you may think maybe it is let's do this
first
let's see can I get a night here vision
for night exchange rooks gonna come here
I have to get off this file soon and
house have to move quick chewing up a
lot of time here precious time let's go
I want to get here it's my main idea
kill that night kill the night coming up
Brooksie one pawn takes i take with the
pun I think it's better to keep this
tension right here there is
possibilities for as long as my e6 pawn
is around there's possibilities for f5
and then this could become a big issue
my main thing get rid of him as soon as
f4 oh now I could go here right away can
you believe that one leave that one mmm
alright let's go here let's see what my
opponent has up their sleeve chop chop
pawn push it's a little bit scary well I
could actually play here next ok now
I've seen a decent reorganization in my
pieces first off though let's get the
Queen out of any nonsense she's watching
over the night so maybe there's
possibilities for me taking on this
square but probably won't want to do
that ok well where do I go Bishop where
do you want to go if I go here I have to
contend with an eventual c5 with tempo
maybe yeah let's just come here I gotta
go quick here I have an advantage almost
for white
tense game tense game as usual usual
I like that if this move this plate I
could take on this square cuz my my
queen is watching over this and then you
know what I can maybe pivot about on the
d5 square I might be wanting to do this
move is not gonna come back to challenge
this guy maybe or maybe take stakes
night here and then I come back to b7 I
think this is the best square for my
queen so I have this capture available
for when this move is played I don't
want to allow the structural change to
occur by way of B 4 and C 5 is gonna be
very annoying establishing a three
versus two majority and a connected
passed pawn this guy still looks a
little bit silly but if there's a
connected passed pawn like that I don't
know let's see let's see
focus here pawn push well I do
flight square this is this this squares
covered a lot I'm not afraid
Emily about a six beef no don't do that
you get hit with c5 I think I want a
flight square let's get a flight square
in there we got heavy pieces on the
board king wants a little a little place
to run wants to be able to run away if
it needs to run he can run what about
rook here I just want the the pawn
structure to be clarified here can we
get that please chop boom boom or just
boom right away right away right away
reinforce this efore night and now this
rook definitely wants to be here maybe I
should have done that instead man let's
go get all my pieces working is this
move gonna be played no you know I could
always chop and then grab on B so that's
something my opponent has to watch out
for or you know what you know what I
might be wanting to do take and then
play here
whoa time issue what do i do what do I
do I'm gonna try it please say it's
gonna be okay
is it gonna be okay I gotta get this d5
square it's the main idea you know what
I also have to do stop a night before
move maybe I want to plant up here on d5
with my queen if I do it right away
night here kicks it away Queen takes
pawn stuff less than 50 for each of us
Oh down to the wire
this is bullet time my mouse better be
treating me well well c 5a v c6 Queen
here opposite the king can weasel my
knight around to f5 maybe at some point
target this guy oh I can keep this night
away I can take this pot and also I
think take the pun yeah let's get rid of
that oh okay hon it's flying definitely
flying it's flying here oh no no no no
no let's take this night before there's
a knight c6 stuff okay now I have a good
night take off the Queen's no one
immediately come here I don't want to
have to deal with knight c6 with tempo
I'm on the bishop my nights are very
good honey whoa okay let's take the
Queen and then it attacked the knight
and then get the pawn so now this is
gonna be a liability back rank issues as
well since have control or f2 just play
my knight here it's got to be right I'm
okay if the knight takes here it's very
sidetracked and I get the beep on
there's no time either now I think I
move this pawn save him the knight moves
I could take here
time good game as usual mr. Wei like all
writing let me back up here my opponent
is typing that the last track of time I
know the feeling I do that too I
definitely do that too okay so let's go
back and flip this board really tense
here so all right
I think tight middle game struggle no
doubt right here a lot of tension you
could see it turning into a hanging pawn
structure and for either side really as
soon as b6 is played takes takes takes
takes and black would be saddled with
the hanging pawn structure or I could
impose similar on white that doesn't
happen in this game but I think white is
standing better here having this knight
on a strong Square and I think we're
things now shift is with this last move
where maybe the evaluation starts to now
change
I think after f4 and me running with
trying to eliminate the defender of
efore and get my knight on this hole in
that hole on that efore square I think
it's maybe starting to now tip in blacks
favor I don't know I can't be sure might
have some might something else have
maybe something else scared me or Bishop
before Knight right there I don't know
this is starting to look pretty good
I think the knight being on that square
very difficult to work around it must be
maybe there's something better instead
of f4 how about night here I guess it
does allow for a Knight to e4 stone I
really don't know I'm struggling to find
a decent improvement maybe instead of
the f4 move seems like it's okay
I don't know water I need some
suggestions here somebody in the twitch
chat throw something out there what else
can maybe white be doing here
because as soon as I start to pivot
about on the e4 square I don't know it
seems like that's gonna be benefiting
black yeah I don't know let me run
further into this one h3 is being
suggested by D winds just making a a
waiting move but I am on that night
three times something has to be done
with that e59 some other crazy
suggestions going on out there a queen
sack queen g4 it's being suggested so I
don't know how about how about maybe
taking the knight in getting this other
one in there and maybe something with f5
I really just don't know it's just too
too tight a position and I don't want to
devote too much time to trying to come
up with something from just this five
minute game of tents as always I mean we
all have both both of us have our pieces
working maybe maybe then ok the knight
move we're also in time pressure maybe
it's best to just run with the c5 move
and I think going with a5 was going to
be important and then maybe even c6 as a
follow up can't be sure but
tight game as usual and the attention
that I've been giving to this game right
here is really on the different pawn
moves and how f4 you know weakens e5 and
maybe there is this c5 ID instead of the
night before but we were built in time
pressure at that point but ok good game
as usual away like